regardless of what you're doing and who
you're doing it for there are people out
there
that are waiting with baited breath to
hear from you to be able to learn from
you to be inspired
by you and
more importantly to invest with you in
their own
growth
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and on this podcast we help you
grow your influence on youtube and then
turn that influence into a high impact
and a high profit online business and
today's episode is brought to you by our
think master class if you didn't know
here at think media we teach free
classes every single week that will help
you learn how to grow your youtube
channel they're not on youtube they're
not on the podcast this is a one hour
free class that you can register for sit
on demand at any time watch that class
and then learn how to grow your youtube
channel so if you've not already
registered for our next upcoming class
you can do that at thinkmasterclass.com
now here on the podcast we are releasing
new episodes every single tuesday so
make sure you are part of our
tuesday tuesdayritual and subscribe
wherever you're listening to this
podcast also if you have a friend who
needs to learn how to grow a youtube
channel then definitely send them the
link to this podcast because this might
be the episode for them i'm excited
because today's episode is actually from
one of our grow with video live sessions
we are in the countdown right now to
grow with video live 2022 and so for
that we want to send you some exclusive
content here on the podcast of some of
our previous uh conferences that we've
had some of our previous sessions and
today's guest is none other than chris
ducker he is the author of youpreneur
and so much of what he's built online is
because of the power of understanding
personal branding we're teaching that
this year at growth video live 2022 in
may in las vegas and so i wanted to give
you just a taste of what growing your
personal brand online can do for you so
let's jump into today's featured content
and then we'll recap at the end
[Music]
over the next sort of 15 to 20 minutes
or so i'm gonna be zipping in and out of
my business of you ecosystem ladder and
this is a five-step process a five-step
process that you can utilize to be able
to build that future-proof business
based around honestly the people that
you want to serve first and foremost but
let's face it you know we spend a lot of
time
quote-unquote at work right so it's
important if you think about it
logically it's very important actually
that we enjoy
what we do while we are at work
otherwise what we've got actually is
just a job we don't want jobs we want to
build businesses and that's what it's
all about so this ecosystem is much like
a lot of other businesses that have
ecosystems attached to it one that you
might probably be quite aware of no
matter where you are in the world is the
coca-cola company coca-cola obviously
been around for eons for decades and
decades and decades and it all started
with one bottle of pop as we would call
it here in the uk or one bottle of soda
as my american brothers and sisters
would say and that is the good
old-fashioned coca-cola that classic
coca-cola product right where the moment
it enters into your mouth you instantly
get a toothache you know that you know
that coca-cola that i'm talking about
however the good news is the coca-cola
and the smart people at that company
have also decided that they can't just
have one product you've got to diversify
you've got to you know put some level of
redundancy
in place and therefore create an
ecosystem
of products around one major product and
then obviously those will
obviously grow and build and run at
their own speed as and when they enter
the market as well
now i started doing this with my uh
youngest company which just turned five
years i own three different businesses
the oldest is almost uh 13 years now the
other one in the middle is 10 years or
so but my youngest business baby is
youpreneur and we actually opened the
doors to youpreneur back in late
2015 we've just hit our fifth year
anniversary and we opened it with a
monthly membership and that monthly
membership was set up primarily to help
people build a business based around
their personal brand right so if you're
an author
a coach a speaker a content creator or
some variety a live streamer youtuber
podcaster whatever it is that you're
doing whatever it is that you're doing
whoever it is that you're serving you
are a personal brand right particularly
for video creators particularly for
youtubers that's exactly what we do
people tune in for us
first and foremost right and then for
everything else that we do thereafter
particularly obviously if they hit the
subscribe button so over the course of
the last five years however what started
as a very relatively small online
community has built itself up to a
full-blown ecosystem of products and
live events and coaching programs and
courses and even merchandise sales as
well and i'm going to go through the
exact system that i used to be able to
hear to go ahead and actually create
this ecosystem for myself and for our
business and for obviously everybody
that we serve but i'm also going to show
you how other people have done it as
well
so one face that you probably will
recognize is amy landino she is a
youtuber she's been on youtube for
many many many years indeed
initially under the brand of savvy sexy
social
and then she kind of rebranded us off at
amy tv and she's all about helping
people go after the life
that they truly want and desire amy
started off like i said on youtube and
she's still
super duper consistent when it comes to
her youtube uh publishing and making
sure that she's hitting all of those or
ticking all of those boxes when it comes
to being discovered and all the rest of
it as well but over time she's gone
ahead and written and published books
she's gone ahead and put together
systems and courses for people to take
to be able to learn how to do what she
has been able to do as well and even
just more recently has put together her
first ever physical
planner product as well and these
particularly
they tend to be relatively popular with
youtubers particularly lifestyle
youtubers right sort of plan your day
plan your work plan your goals that sort
of type of thing she sold out 500 copies
of this planner actually in less than 48
hours i think like 33 hours or something
like that so amy is the perfect example
of that personal brand utilizing video
but now has obviously flourished and
grown a business based around what she
did on youtube another person that you
definitely do know is this guy right
here my buddy roberto blake i love
roberto blake i often say other than
sean and i have to say this obviously
because it's his event other than sean
roberto is the guy that i turn to when
it comes to learning how to do youtube
right but again hustling like crazy
building out a great channel of
dedicated subscribers developing all
these opportunities for people to be
able to learn and become inspired in
with what they're doing
go ahead and create a podcast it's not
even a video podcast a regular audio
podcast that people can tune into to be
able to learn even more
from roberto he's put together you know
physical products or rather digital
products that be able to help people to
kick-start their youtube uh
kind of channel on their presence on
youtube and make sure that they're
looking good and feeling good when
they're on video and he's also got a
membership community where he charges
obviously a regular monthly fee for
people to be able to
access exclusive content that he serves
up on a regular basis now this is all
part of that ecosystem that i showed you
earlier on we just happened to get going
with our monthly membership but up until
that point
i was actually already building my own
personal brand
and i remember somebody asking me at a
conference probably in late 2012 they
asked me you know how do i build a
personal brand and honestly i didn't
have an answer for them although
retrospectively looking back at that
conversation it was clear that i had
already been doing it in fact actually
i've been doing it for many many many
years indeed and the reason why is
because
a personal brand is basically what
people say about us
when we're not around
right like when we're not at that
conference when we're not at that dinner
party or when we're not at that coffee
meeting right what are people saying
about you
when you're not around
that right there
is your reputation and ultimately it's
your personal brand right so i want you
to kind of just you know either grab a
quick snapshot of this put it up on the
socials tag me at chrisducker let me
know what you think of this and anything
else that we're going to be going
through
today i will say though that there's one
thing that so many people are falling or
tripping over
when it comes to this particular journey
and that is
impostor syndrome you know what it's
like right we pick up our phones we
start scrolling through our favorite
social media feeds and we start looking
at what other people are doing other
lives look so much more in check their
lives look so much more calculated their
lives look so much more successful you
know what i'm talking about this
impostor syndrome is killing our
generation
of entrepreneurs and i don't use that
term lightly at all there are people
stressing out they're burning out
because of this and here's the thing you
cannot you should not and you absolutely
should stay away 100 from comparing
somebody else's 100th step or 200th or
500th step
to your first step to your eighth to
your ninth or to your 20th step
let me know what you think about this in
the comments as well i'd love to be able
to read back and look back on this one
likewise our job really here when we
talk about building the business of you
it's kind of like it's the business of
us it's the business of me right like
our job is to become somebody's
favorites
let me say that again so it kind of
really
gets into your brain like your job
is to become
somebody's
favorite grab a piece of paper or a pen
what are the things that you do right
now
what are you doing right now
that will help you become
somebody's
favorite
you've got to jot them down
lean into doing more of that be
unapologetically uniquely you
at all times when you're building the
business of you because if you don't
you're going to trip up at some point
you don't have to live somebody else's
life
particularly on the internet just live
yourself
live your own
life become somebody's favorite
somebody's favorite youtuber somebody's
favorite podcaster somebody's favorite
author somebody's favorite cartoonist
somebody's favorite business coach
health and fitness coach it doesn't
matter what it is just become somebody's
favorite and what happens when you have
that mentality and you go into this with
that mentality your vibe ultimately
attracts your tribe
right your vibe attracts your tribe
however
before anything can happen with any of
this we need to get clear on how
we'll actually serve those that we
attract into
our ecosystem and this leads me
to a really important exercise that i
cannot stress enough for everybody to
make sure that they do whether it's
today when the conference is over maybe
in one of the break times or maybe you
know at the end of this entire thing a
couple days from now you absolutely must
work on your personal brand
statement that you paner personal brand
statement here's my statement
my personal brand statement is i help
people become the go-to leader in their
industry and build future proof
businesses i want to break this down
because it's important to do this
there's two different sections of this
statement which are incredibly
incredibly important for you to capture
and understand and it's based on the
benefits of working with me as a
business coach as well
as the outcome of working with me as
well let me break it down and show you
what i mean first up i help people
become the go-to leader in their
industry that's a benefit right it's a
benefit to be seen as the go-to expert
regardless of what niche you're in right
i say niche
and not niche because i know there's
probably more american people tuning in
than there are british but hey niche
niche potato potato chamomile chamomile
whatever i don't know we could go all
day on this but there's that first
section right there to help people
become that go-to leader in their
industry that's the benefit the outcome
of me working with them is that i will
help you build a future proof
business it's a business that is not
going to be affected or very likely to
be affected by any outside forces
because when you build the business of
you it's 100
in your hands all
the time
so that's your personal brand statement
i want you to consider that start
breaking it down right now a benefit of
working with you or buying your products
or using your service whatever it is and
then the actual outcome of doing so as
well
the whole point in this is that we mark
it like a magnet right just like at
first what happens is when you utilize a
magnet you're attracting
the right people
into your ecosystem you're attracting
the right people to your youtube channel
or your podcast feeds but at the exact
same time and this is why it's so
so incredibly exciting
is that you are repelling away just like
a magnet does it attracts and repels you
are repelling away the people that
should not be
in that ecosystem you know the types of
people on day
29 of your 30-day money-back guarantee
they're gonna email wanting their money
back we don't need
those people
in our lives we definitely don't need
those people in our business sucking out
our day our time every day right so you
attract the best and you repel
the rest mark it like a magnet you see
at first when you get going a lot of you
are probably a little bit further along
here but allow me to just recap for
those that maybe are at the beginning of
this journey that we're all on together
at first what happens is you'll create
content that you think
that's the key word hence the
highlighted color on the screen you
think
your audience will want to see from you
you know what it's like you you hit
publish on your first 20 30 videos
whatever it is but then something
miraculous happens
you find your tribe
and that tribe wants to be
around you a tribe wants to spend time
with you this is a photo of one probably
about a third of the stage at our youtu
summit event which takes place in london
every november unfortunately not this
year but i'll get over it but they'll
want to be with you and then what
happens is later on once you build up
those relationships with people
you'll then be able to figure out
and realize that you can actually create
content that you know and this is where
the power is that you know your audience
wants
and needs
from you
right the answers to their questions
solutions to their problems
and that's where the real
real magic starts to happen and this is
where the business of you
ecosystem ladder comes into play i'm
gonna start breaking this down
for you roll up your sleeves
if you've got a long sleeve shirt on
like me roll them up because we're about
to get to work first up
there are five main sections on the
ladder and no you cannot achieve all
five in one year it doesn't work that
way you've got to put in your time
you've got to earn your stripes
to use a nice military colloquialism
so first up
at the very very beginning of this
entire ladder we have
our building
of our audience level now this is
actually something that carries on
forever like you're always wanting to
create new opportunities to be found and
discovered by other people right but
right at the beginning we've got to have
that focus on building your audience now
i know a lot of people tuning in this
conference are going to be active on
youtube and clearly that's a great
platform and it's where it's all the
actions at right now i get it but don't
forget my friends that you must build
out your own hub your own home
as well
you don't own youtube
google does
but you can own whatever your name is
dot com like i do and it's important
that you build out that own that that
hub that you own
fully that you control
fully when you want to make changes you
make changes if you don't want to and
things are working well you just leave
it alone now that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't utilize platforms like youtube
or a podcast for example to build that
audience and obviously consistency is
key here to show up very regularly we
should always be using these other
platforms to build the business of you
but don't forget you've got our own your
own platform as well so that's step one
building your audience
step number two
on the ladder
is all about
amplifying your message or spreading
your message
out
and then ultimately
starting to really zoom in on
positioning yourself as that go-to
leader as that expert
in your niche now i want you to just
think real quick one or two things jot
them down
one or two things
what separates you from everyone else in
your industry that's actually going to
be what positions you as an expert but
what separates you i'll take a sip of
water and i want you to think about that
just for 10 seconds make some notes how
do you start and grow a youtube channel
that makes you money and also makes a
major impact in the lives of people it's
safe to say that youtube is the most
popular video platform in the world it's
the second largest search engine and the
second most popular social media
platform and now it has over 2.3 billion
monthly active users that's a lot but
how do you stand out in the rising
competition what are the newest features
and the best strategies working right
now to get views what are the most
proven ways to build your personal brand
you'll learn all of that at the number
one youtube marketing conference for
entrepreneurs and business-minded
content creators grow with video live
secure your ticket today at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post to secure your
limited time discounted ticket
okay whatever that is you got to lean
more
into that and by the way i'd love to see
anybody that hand writes notes and
things like that if you want to take a
photo tag me on instagram at chrisducker
in your stories i'd love to see your
notes from today's session genuinely i
get a real kick out of that like most
speakers do
so when we talk about amplifying your
message we talk about positioning
yourself as an expert yes the press is
there and we want to try and get a hold
of all of that and i've been very
blessed to be uh talked about and
featured in all of these outlets but in
today's world if i had to pick one
particular way to amplify my message and
spread my message it would be via
becoming a guest on people's podcasts
for me without a doubt without a doubt
it's brought more people into my
ecosystem as a strategy or a tactic than
any other that i've worked on so
generally think about the and by the way
you don't want to be on every podcast
that's on itunes or spotify just the
ones that are relevant
to your customer base just
those that are relevant to those you
personally are wanting to serve
the next step on the ladder
is all about leveraging your community
to continue to spread that message maybe
even potentially publishing a book or
even launching and growing
a membership as well this is about
having that community
around you it's about getting people
into your world as much as possible
and it's not an ego thing i want to
clarify that i know i look very happy in
the middle here
maybe somewhat enraptured with joy some
might say but the fact of the matter is
as i stand there with my two daughters
and my sons my my wife they're just
below me there
that right there is my highlight of the
year being able to have not only my
family but also
all of these incredible community
members around me it's absolutely huge
and what do you think they're doing when
they're at my live event with me what do
you think they're doing when they do
anything with me even online they're
talking about it they're sharing what's
going on
so think about
what you could potentially do in the
next eight
12 maybe 18 months or so when it comes
to bringing your community together
on a regular basis and it doesn't
necessarily need to be in person this is
the inside of the youtuner academy our
membership please you know don't don't
don't try and get too many people into a
facebook group either facebook groups
are great for
everyday kind of chit chat type stuff
but don't give you don't give too much
of your soul away to a facebook group
okay because again you don't own
facebook zuckerberg and his buddies do
you want to try and get them off of
other people's platforms and onto your
own so think about a membership think
about putting your overall philosophy as
a personal brand entrepreneur somebody
building a business based around
themselves their personality what they
stand for think about putting that
philosophy in the pages of a book as
well if nothing else it becomes the most
perfect 15 business card for you when
you're meeting prospective customers or
event organizers if you want to speak at
them and so on and so on
it's been absolutely huge publishing
books and i often say that
you know publishing a book and putting a
book out into the world is one of the
easiest and fastest ways of establishing
yourself as an expert as well
step number four i hope you guys are
following me along quite nicely here
step number four
is all about taking what we've done so
far maybe we're making a little bit of
money at this point as well which is
always a bonus obviously but you can see
it's a long game
approach here this isn't a cash grab in
any way whatsoever this is about playing
the long game right to you i'm a big
basketball fan
i'm about as unbritish as a brit as
you'll ever meet actually i'm all about
the nba boston celtics if there's any
lakers or pistons fans in the house
we're not gonna it's just not gonna work
out between us but a big boston celtics
fan larry legend and all the rest of it
to use that analogy this is about
playing with the fourth quarter in mind
it's not just about having an incredible
first or second quarter this is about
knowing that there's a long game ahead
of us we got to conserve our energy
we've got to conserve our you know our
plays we've got to try and not utilize
the same plays over and over and over
again and eventually with a little bit
of luck when the buzzer goes at the end
of the game will be victorious same
thing when you're building a business of
you so we do this slowly bit by bit step
four here is about making more money
quite frankly it's all about making
money from here on in and if you're like
any other entrepreneur that i've ever
come across chances are quite like the
idea of making money and that's fine and
in fact actually if there's a time in
this journey for you to get just a
little bit selfish
about profiting from all of this
now's the time to do it
it's okay to be a little selfish not too
selfish not too selfish but a little
selfish when it comes to making money
because if you don't make money all
you've got is another hobby
i don't need another hobby i got mouths
to feed
so step four
is about monetizing and that's all about
building out that flagship digital
course that is a major port of call for
anybody that comes into your ecosystem
right out of the gate you want to hit
him with that straightaway this is where
you can learn all my best stuff this is
the springboard you need to be able to
do abc xyz whatever it might be
you might even consider jumping on a
stage or two whether they be in person
or maybe for the foreseeable future
virtually just like this with some
speaking you could even bring on board a
group coaching program maybe you're
working with 10 or 20 or even 100 people
one too many not one-on-one
one to many and we're gonna be talking
into the different ways you can monetize
in the final section of this talk
so stand by for that
it's also about potentially maybe
bringing on board some sponsors as well
whether it be for a virtual event like
this or maybe you're a podcast or a
video show maybe you're live streaming
on a weekly basis and you've got a
sponsor teed up for that as well
whatever happens right now this is about
utilizing everything we've done up to
this point from step one
building that audience which is a very
highly valuable commodity in today's
world amplifying that message getting
more people into your ecosystem becoming
the go-to person in your industry
leveraging that community to help spread
the word through potentially maybe
publishing a book or launching a
membership now we're starting to
monetize in bigger and better ways with
step four one of the favorite things for
me to do is to speak i love speaking on
stage it's one of my favorite favorite
activities
but also opening up the doors to a group
coaching platform has taught me well you
know what actually it's great to be able
to stand up on stage or present
virtually in front of a camera and help
people that way but if i can work
one-to-many with them over the course of
a year for example
then i get the opportunity to really
truly affect change in their lives in
their business in their mindset to hold
them accountable to hold their feet to
the fire to make sure that they actually
achieve their goals
that gets me out of bed in the morning
and
at the very same time
it also helps me make a little bit of
money as well so i can continue to grow
and do what i'm doing for the people in
my community
a step number five
this is where we pour the gasoline all
over that monetization fire
a multi-day conference is a given there
is nothing
nothing more special than bringing your
people together
in person
in person
when it's not illegal to do it again you
want to bring them in person
and create those opportunities for them
to
mix
and learn about each other to partner up
with each other i've even had people at
my conference i i
many years ago we held a conference and
one of the attendees ending up getting
engaged to one of the speakers
at that event
now they broke up a few years after but
nonetheless it works right this is all
about that p to p all that people to
people connections that so many people
are striving for nowadays
it also gives you the opportunity to be
able to create a high-end mastermind
where you're bringing people
together
in person and don't misunderstand like
when you start putting together big
conferences where you can fly your own
flags outside historic venues or whether
you're on stage
at the exact same venue the exact same
stage where they announced the prime
minister in the uk like this stuff right
here
is what people want to see when they're
part of your community and to be able to
bring people
into that inner circle that high end in
a circle where you're charging tens of
thousands of dollars to be part of that
intimate group
people want
this
now
more so than ever before and the reason
why is because we all
want to fast-track
our own journeys as much as possible and
here's the thing
regardless of what you're doing and who
you're doing it for there are people out
there that are waiting with baited
breath to hear from you to be able to
learn from you to be inspired
by you
and
more importantly to invest with you in
their own
growth
and in their own advancement regardless
of what it is that you're going to help
them with they will be more than happy
to invest in themselves and ultimately
spend money with you in order to be able
to download all that experience that
you've got
into their own data bank and speed up
their own journeys
again it's not a cash grab scenario this
is about providing a service to other
people based around your uniqueness and
the people that you truly honestly want
to serve
the thing here though is as we're
building out this ecosystem
is to understand that you can only do
one thing at a time right remember that
old acronym to focus
follow
one course
until
success it's very very true we can't
multitask it's a myth
there you go i said it multitasking is a
myth our brains are not wired to work on
one or more than one really important
thing at any one time so complete these
parts of the ecosystem by the way this
is just mine it doesn't necessarily mean
that yours is going to be identical it
could be very very different but
complete these individual steps as when
you're building out your own ladder
one at a time you work on one set of
goals to completion
and then you move on to the next one but
most importantly
most importantly
more than anything else
understand that you must be seen
to sell
in order to build
influence
if you're going to be just throwing out
all of your experience all of your
expertise for free
all the time you're just going to be
able to attract freebie collectors you
know the type of people
they sign up to every newsletter on the
internet they download the ebooks they
put them in a special folder
in their dropbox
and they never even open them
or very rarely will they read or go
through the entire thing you don't need
those people you might need them
initially at the very beginning of
building that audience structure but
sooner or later you're gonna have to
create something that has a dollar
amount attached to it you must be seen
to sell
please and whatever you do charge what
you're worth
as well
always charge what you're worth
so this is our final stretch together
here like the last 10 minutes where what
i'm gonna do is go through
my starting
five you can see i'm a basketball fan my
starting five monetization strategies
when you've built if we go back to the
ladder very very quickly when you've
built the audience you've amplified
everything you've leveraged your
messaging you've worked with your
community to build things out you're
starting to make money and you're doing
well
with all of this involved it has to
start somewhere and with the starting
five monetization strategies this gives
you five ideas that you can get started
with
straight away not necessarily in rolling
out but at least planning right at least
planning them
number one
is coaching now i will say that this is
not necessarily the most scalable
approach of monetizing your expertise
because obviously there's only so much
one-on-one work we can do one-on-one
coaching although it's the lowest
hanging monetization fruit
it's not scalable because there's only
so many hours in the day and if you go
in one-on-one with somebody you are
ultimately trading your time for dollars
now as long as you're charging what
you're worth we can live with that for a
little while but sooner or l
with coaching or consulting
the second way that we can monetize our
expertise is through affiliate marketing
now this is kind of almost like an
indirect way and sean and the team i
think media
are
ballers when it comes to this like they
do
incredibly well with affiliate marketing
that they do this is ultimately where
you are given or you are giving a link
to your viewers to your listeners to
your readers whatever it might be and if
they click on that link and they buy
something you get a commission
for it now i will say there's the right
way to do this and then with most other
ways of looking at making money there's
a wrong way of doing this as well you
don't want to just throw one option
after another you don't want to blanket
your community
with a whole different affiliate
marketing deals that's not going to help
you in the long run what you want to do
is look at the two or three things three
or four things that you feel your
community needs above and beyond
everything else to succeed in whatever
it is that you're helping them with
and set up good deals
with those companies or with those
service providers or product providers
or whatever it is that when you
introduce new customers to them you get
a little kickback everybody's happy do
it the right way don't do it the sleazy
way the third way to be able to monetize
yourself is through your own products
and
services so for many many years i've
been uh seen as an expert in the virtual
staffing niche uh and i'm still running
two different businesses within that
outsourcing and va niche to this day so
virtual virtualstarfinder.com which is
our va recruiting hub it was a
no-brainer that i was to open up a
business providing a service where busy
entrepreneurs can find good quality
filipino virtual assistants and to this
date actually we've done over 8 000 vas
are being hired through our service in
the last 10 years of being a business so
again it's just about finding that gap
in that market and going ahead and
bridging it between whatever problem and
solution there is out there
the fourth way to be able to monetize
your expertise is through
memberships now it's not necessarily the
most passive of income opportunities
that are out there however it is a great
way to be able to bring people together
and obviously the beautiful thing about
managing a membership
kind of product or service is that you
get predictable reliable income on a
regular basis whether you're billing
people weekly monthly quarterly yearly
whatever it might be it's that
predictable reliable income that let's
face it every business owner loves the
idea of having that in their ecosystem
and then lastly
events as i alluded to not so long ago
for me the most important thing that i
do every year is i bring my people
together and although we're not doing it
in person this year we will figure out a
way in fact we have figured out a way to
be able to do it virtually which we're
letting our community know about a
little bit later on in um early october
but the fact of the matter is events
bring people together you want to be
seen and i want to put this kind of as i
wrap up and and sort of just if i can
leave you with anything here if i may as
a geek i will use a star wars analogy
for you to understand this
we don't want to be
luke skywalker
as the heads of our communities as the
business owners of our companies we
don't want to be the hero we don't want
to be luke
what we want to be
is obi-wan
we want to be the wise old guys we want
to show our customers our community
members our subscribers how to do things
because when everything in the world
goes back to quote-unquote normal
whatever that might end up looking like
or whenever somebody discovers you and
and they watch just one single video and
can change their lives almost instantly
if not a little further down the line
when we do that as the obi-wan character
as the guide and not trying to make it
all about us with our sexy blue
lightsaber like luke does it's all about
helping
our people in our communities in fact
if anything we want to be shining the
light on
our community members and on our
customers as the heroes we want our
customers to be luke we can be obi-wan
if that makes sense and bringing people
together is what it's all about
that's my starting five when it comes to
building the business of you
and to wrap up i want to leave you
with one simple thought and as far as
i'm concerned although it might only be
one man's opinion i stand by this as a
very very strong opinion and that is
that
when you build the business of you
it's 100 percent
original
remember what i said it's about being
unapologetically
and uniquely
you
so that you mark it like a magnet bring
people into your world bring them into
the ecosystem provide the solutions to
their problems because at the very core
of every entrepreneur that's what we
should be doing and that's what we
should be focused on anyway
forget all the bells and whistles and
the vanity metrics of social media and
all the rest of it provide a solution to
people's problems
lean into your uniqueness build the
business of you because when you do it
it's 100 original and it cannot be
copied
ever
that's my time with you today i very
very very much appreciate
the opportunity to be able to spend some
time with you like i said hit me up on
instagram subscribe to my youtube
channel if you want to know more about
this stuff and i'd love to see any notes
that you've written down in anything at
all it could be in toilet paper for all
i care take snap shot make sure you
chris duck and me on instagram i'd love
to converse with you and sean on the
team thank you very much for allowing me
the opportunity to spend some time with
your community
well i hope that brought value to you
and man isn't chris just such a great
teacher i could listen to him all day
because i love his accent and i love
what he is teaching he breaks it down so
simply so my question to you is what is
the action you need to take next what
one of those steps do you need to
implement next in your business and
are you actually
online to grow your personal brand have
you thought about even just that
question i remember when i first started
as an entrepreneur i was nervous about
what type of content i should be putting
out there who i was trying to reach i
didn't really know what i was doing but
i can tell you more and more as i've
focused on building a personal brand
which just means putting heather out
online in a way that is helpful to other
people and not in a selfish content way
it has been the catalyst of growing here
not on just the podcast but just
personally online and so i want to
encourage you to take the steps and take
the action items that chris has given
you and put them into action and if you
want to we'll link down in the
description box below as well as if
you're listening to this audio version
in the show notes all the places that
you can go and follow chris and support
what he is doing online now again that
episode was a exclusive access for you
as uh being part of our think media
family over here on the podcast from our
grow with video live sessions this year
is going to be incredible so if you have
not gotten your tickets yet to grow with
video live you can go to
growthvideolive.com and see the early
bird access that we still have available
for you there's a couple different
levels that you can go to we have
general admission we have vip and then
we're also offering a platinum
experience for you business owner who's
listening right now so you can go to
growthvideolive.com
we've got some incredible speakers
coming this year that you don't want to
miss so growth videolive.com is where
you can go to grab those tickets now if
you have been a listener to this podcast
for any length of time you know that my
favorite thing to do on every single
episode is get to read your reviews if
you are over on apple podcast you can
rate and review this podcast to help
other creators and entrepreneurs just
like you know that this is the place for
them and today's uh listener is j
barbara 87 jay barbara says this is a
must listen i've learned youtube
marketing hiring a team online marketing
course creation affiliate marketing and
so much more this is one of my top
podcasts jay barbara thank you so much
for being a part of our community it
means so much to me to see that we are
helping you grow not just your youtube
channel but also your team your business
and
helping you learn how to do course
creation uh here on the podcast youtube
channel
we actually offer bonus episodes and
i've actually shared now a few different
ones on how to actually start and grow a
course here at think media we have
broken into the eight figures of course
creation and so i am passing along the
knowledge that i wish i knew when we
first got started so you can check all
that out here on the youtube channel if
you're watching this or if you're
listening while you're driving walking
your dog doing the dishes you can always
subscribe over on the youtube channel to
get more free content we actually have a
show that's happening called the growth
video live show that is happening on the
youtube channel you can get access to
that by just going over there for free
and subscribing well i want to thank you
so much for being a part of what we're
doing here at think media thank you so
much for showing up every single week
thank you for your reviews and your
comments i cannot believe what we've
been able to create together we have
some incredible content coming to you
here on the podcast over the next
several weeks heading into the spring
and summer so make sure you're
subscribed so you can get all access to
everything we're doing here at think
media thanks for being a part of what
we're doing and we'll catch you in the
next episode did you hear that growth
video live 2022 is back in person this
is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room they're going so fast so
make sure you get your ticket right now
at growthvideolive.com